people shout let's go Brandon during Joe
Biden's visit to Kentucky and there's a
picture of Joe Brown of Joseph I was
going to say Joe Brandon Joe Brandon
sorry we just made you mess up on all
the news once you've done one wrong
you're just gonna read that it's fine
why are you redowskiing so much Tim I
don't know what's going on here maybe
you know maybe I just haven't had enough
you know sugar or something yeah I've
got zero sugar today yeah all right
President Joe Biden was met with shouts
of let's go Brandon and a trump flag as
he arrived in Kentucky on Wednesday to
survey damage from a tornado that killed
at least 88 people uh we know what let's
go Brandon means so they got videos and
photos two let's go Brandon's from the
crowd as Biden gets out after arriving
in the state Biden tweeted I'm in
Kentucky to me with local leaders in a
survey the damage from the tornadoes in
extreme weather it will take all of us
working together to recover and begin
rebuilding and we are committed to
providing whatever support is needed for
however long it takes earlier in the day
Biden spoke with Kentucky Governor Andy
Bashir and was briefed on the damage
while in Mayfield Department of Homeland
Security secretary Alejandro mayorcas
was also present and that's basically it
that's the gist of the story but I think
this is an important uh important story
yeah I feel like under the years of the
former president even like I I go back
to I'm a political nerd so even back to
like when Romney was running or McCain
was running or when George W Bush was in
the White House I remember living on
34th Street in New York City and half a
million people were like burning his
Effigies right and it was like a news
story of look how mad they are at the
Republican in office and and like
protesters Free Speech yay but it's also
one-sided like here's two dudes which
you know two dudes ain't that many I
feel like most the people in Kentucky
are probably legitimately mourning and
worried about their homes and their
neighbors and the businesses in the area
and what are they going to do with the
rest of their lives and their priority
isn't to go out there and yell let's go
Brandon but kudos to the guys who did
and they have a right to do that and and
so but you're not going to get coverage
of this anywhere else because heaven
forbid people who are against Joe Biden
Express their you know viewpoints I
think they have a right to say it I
think it's important that people speak
up especially in the face of Joe Biden I
think that's what makes America great
the fact that Joe Biden can come down
and you can yell let's go Brandon what's
what's awesome about this country and
part of me is though like man I wish we
could kind of just get like we have a
major disaster 80 people died yeah but
Joe Biden is just he's burning this
country to the ground and I'm not going
to blame him for the natural disaster
but so many people are suffering in this
country because of his failed leadership
for someone to get that opportunity to
be like I am going to criticize you over
everything we're dealing with well and
if you look at it you got to do it even
NPR I think I was listening to NPR
earlier today and they were talking
about how this area was already hard hit
by the economy and then you have a
tornado that comes through and levels
the entire town so there and this guy's
gonna do a photo op and he's and that
and so I get the frustration of local
people that are like okay now you're
coming now you're pretending to do
something now you're gonna send us funds
now you're pretending to care when we've
lost our factory jobs and we've done all
this stuff and like this quote unquote
return to normal that you promised
hasn't happened Well Middle America has
been I think most screwed over by the
establishment whether it was the opioid
epidemic whether it's even gas prices
going up this predominantly affects
people in rural rural areas like
Kentucky where they have to drive around
they spend more on gas they spend more
and on energy and utilities but this is
not a rare occurrence I still remember
at the end of the Bush presidency there
was also an incident where he was out
there surveying some kind of
environmental damage and then people
came up and screamed a few Bush they
also did it to Dick Cheney but his poll
numbers are extremely down and I think
the few people who are supporting him
are some cartel members the Taliban and
a few billionaires that really make up
the few percentage points of support
that he gets in China yeah yes yes good
big fan taking it taking advantage right
now he's meeting with Putin and they're
basically joining together because Biden
is is
well it's look I don't want war in
Ukraine I don't want war in Afghanistan
but Joe Biden wow did he screw up
Afghanistan and that's really when his
poll numbers took a huge hit because he
he's he is a failed leader I think with
a lot of stuff especially inflation the
reason people are mad at the
establishment altogether yeah a lot of
people are in these cities and they they
can't see it they don't understand when
the prices go up a little bit they're
not thinking about it and it's
incremental if every day you wake up
they add you know a nickel or whatever
to the food it's going to take you a
little while to be like hey wait a
minute why is the milk costing so much
but when you get news story like people
are screaming and dying and a bomb went
off in Afghanistan and our you know the
the withdrawal was a huge disaster
all of a sudden people there's something
tangible they can see there I gotta say
though I think for average Americans
outside the Beltway outside you know
these liberal meccas where everybody's
making a quarter of a million dollars a
year and they're like stem jobs right
um that you have people like me that I
go to the grocery store every week with
my kids and that does affect us fuel
prices do affect us my parents lives 30
miles from the closest grocery store you
have people watching right now that you
know have to commute maybe 50 miles to
work one day uh one way and so those
things even though it is like
incremental they still feel that when
they look at their paycheck and they're
like well that thousand bucks ain't
gonna go as far this week and I think
that that angst can continue into the
midterms but I don't know voters have
short-term memory and obviously his
ratings are not good his his polling
numbers are not too hot and I don't I
don't blame they're absolutely so bad
um but I think that there's an element
of most of the time people vote with
what affects them like in that moment
voting is an emotional appeal and
typically liberals tend to do a better
job at telling a story but the story
that they're telling the story that
they're showing and the story that
they're governing right now is a total
crap show and and I think it's going to
really hurt them next year what I think
is absolutely crazy is that Biden's
approval rating was as high as it was
for as long as it was especially
compared to Trump when we got Donald
Trump in office the economy started
doing better in 2019 I heard over and
over again how good the economy was from
from news reports from individuals when
we were buying furniture for the first
Studio we built the furniture sales lady
was just like 2019 was the greatest year
of my life I can't believe how much
money I made I'm so happy the guy who
was doing the um foundation work as we
were expanding outside he was like
business is booming and that was January
of 2020. yep and then what happened yeah
but take a look what's really
fascinating we have this Joe Biden's
Real Clear Politics poll average it's
right around it's Afghanistan yeah where
he really got slammed yeah and that's
why it's fascinating to me that it was
literally screwing up getting out of
Afghanistan where things start to flip
and I think what may have happened is
that moment was a big slap in the face
to a lot of people who are who are
content to be like Trump is gone
everything's fine yeah and then all of a
sudden they were like a bomb just went
off and killed a bunch of people outside
of the the airport yeah Air Force Base
was abandoned and I think left right or
Center even like you said okay I didn't
want to be in war in Afghanistan you
don't want to abandon our own people and
there is thank God this beauty to
America and our citizens that whether
you look like me or vote like me I'm
still not gonna like abandon you in
another country well like and I'm not
going to lead you to die and I think
that there has been this element of your
commander-in-chief does not leave you
behind there's you know all of the
situations like Reagan with the Iran
hostages you know other situations of
even Obama who paid to get some people
out of Iran that like we we don't leave
our guys behind we don't leave our
people behind and it was a wake-up call
and I think very shocking to a lot of
Americans like holy wait what this just
happened and nobody's gonna do anything
about it and they're just pretending
like it's no big deal I was surprised
the moment people didn't wake up was
true in it on a shopping to pressure
yeah
well the mainstream media pretty much
got him into office they're supporting
him throughout the way but now that you
see the cracks uh in the facade that
they kind of painted of him as this kind
of trump savior he's not a trump savior
what happened in Afghanistan was an
absolute geopolitical failure that of
course gave billions of dollars of
Weaponry to the Taliban and the
retaliation against the attack on the
base was literally killing 10 innocent
civilians seven of them children U.S Aid
workers that were providing water and
just recently as of a few hours ago the
Pentagon announced that they will be
holding no one responsible for the
Butcher and assassination of innocent
civilians in Afghanistan that the media
and the Pentagon were telling us was
Isis K members that were going to launch
a preemptive strike on the embassy that
wasn't true they were lying through
their teeth and this is one reason why
again Biden totally out of touch with
reality he had to have a PR campaign
disinformation group to meeting with the
corporate media in order to paint a
positive picture on the economy wow and
and today he even issued his statement
saying what's the big deal when talking
about giving up freedoms in exchange for
of course the vaccine mandates totally
out of touch totally totalitarian to me
he's a puppet that many special
interests are using to push very
unpopular policies on the American
people did he get a command man in there
when he said to give up your freedoms
nope
clearly yeah
and he was like you know what's up
the more dictatorial he is the clearer
he speaks I'm old enough to remember my
background has been talk radio and I
produce the Hannity radio show for seven
years and I remember there was a time
where it was like Hugh Hewitt might have
been Dennis Prager Mark Levin Sean
Hannity like the ogs of of conservative
right radio met with George W bush in
his second term and it might have been a
time when his poll numbers were down and
there was like all of these mainstream
media reports once the meeting was
leaked of oh look white house conspires
with far-right media and like try to
boost the president's poll numbers but
yet you have like you said not just not
just you know The Young Turks and like
crazy leftist organizations that claim
to be unbiased media Outlets uh going
and talking to people in the White House
communications team you have members of
the mainstream media Outlets that
pretend to be
fair and balanced journalists that are
doing this and like where is the outrage
just I think the double standard is what
really gets to me there's two things
I'll add first is there was a CNN
producer who was arrested for
trafficking kids and Brian stelter's on
Twitter like why won't the fox hosts
talk about the text messages and it's
like they did well it was 24 hours later
and it's like when are you gonna talk
about the person yeah Chris Cuomo and
your producer the producer who worked
with Chris or even the CIA Scandal where
they caught their own agents doing some
of those same similar actions but MSNBC
ABC News CBS NBC all ignored this major
CNN producers but I got to add one more
thing too about what happened in
Afghanistan I'll tell you where I think
I wish more Americans would give Biden a
lower rating is when he what did he do
he did it he issued a drone strike which
killed 10 civilians was it 10 10
civilians seven children and it was an
aid worker that was providing clean
water to The Afghani people and uh how
many of the uh is anybody involved going
to be I don't know maybe indicted go to
prison or the Pentagon just announced no
one will be held responsible for this
action so Joe Biden following his
predecessor Barack Obama
kills children now I'm not going to give
Trump a a an escape on this one the
difference is with with Barack Obama we
know definitively that he killed Abdul
Rahman alawlaki in a drone strike in
Yemen we know definitively that Joe
Biden's Administration they had issued
this drone strike when it comes to
Donald Trump and the death of Abdullah
man's little sister this is this is a
Commando raid in Yemen it's speculated
that she died it's it's so it's still
bad and I don't want to give Trump any
free passes on passes on his drone
strikes or his Commando raids and the
and the stuff he did but I'm also going
to say Donald Trump also moved to
withdraw from Afghanistan and Syria and
and didn't start any new Wars and I'll
take what I can get criticism where
where criticism is due praise or praise
is due Joe Biden I knew this was going
to happen you get him in office and he
was going to restart the war machine the
same we saw in the in the Years prior
well and I think that we all kind of
expected that in 2016 had it been
Hillary Clinton who won and I think that
that's why you saw people
um specifically like those Rust Belt
people where Hillary didn't spend any
money you know that decided to vote for
Trump because it was a breath of fresh
air and people were War weary now as
someone who knows and loves many members
of the military I don't know the details
of that Commando thing and I've never
been on the ground with a gun to my head
and having to kill bad guys and
unfortunately there is a cost-benefit
analysis to every single decision that
you make as commander-in-chief right
like if you actually it is kind of
fascinating to go back and look at the
Obama decision to go get in Bin Laden
and how the guys in the room all had
different percentages of what they
thought the likelihood of one Bin Laden
actually being there and then two it
being like a no-fault operation and the
and that that risk is extremely high and
that's part of their job but yeah I do
appreciate the consistency that you have
there it's just also once again the
media would be blowing up everything had
an aid worker been killed in a drone
strike by how much but just really quick
there wasn't a lot of consistency with
the official story of what Obama did to
uh Osama and then it the raid that
Donald Trump committed that allegedly
killed anawaki's sister uh was literally
the raid that Obama didn't want to do
but but Donald Trump personally called
off on and there was civilian casualties
according to many independent reports
I'll say this though that was really
early in in Trump's Administration Trump
switched to to getting American
Personnel out and upping drone strikes
I'm not a big fan of that necessarily
but I suppose it's like what do you do
right you you say we don't want ground
conflict so to secure certain areas you
need drones
Donald Trump tried getting us out of
Syria and he was lied to by whatever
whatever you want to call these people
you know uh the bureaucratic State how
about that the administrative State they
lied to the American people and to
Donald Trump to make sure that that we
kept troops in Syria when he and the
American people don't want these wars so
I will give him credit for that and I
will I will say this speaking of Hillary
Clinton
we're just really quick also I want to
add that Donald Trump made sure that the
list of people that were assassinated by
the drone strikes was Kept Secret away
from the general public Obama at least
executed people kept the list uh let's
be honest with each other but but Trump
also took away the decision for him
personally calling off on these
assassinations and gave it to the
Pentagon as well so I think that's an
important factor to to understand here
and I wish he would have pulled troops
out correctly out of Afghanistan but you
mean like you want the transparency of
it yes exactly reporting like if you're
going to kill a 15 year old American
citizen which Obama did and his
spokesperson told me and and we are
changed reporters that they should have
had a better father at least to be open
and transparent about it that was that
was massive that was back about 2012.
yep that was during the presidential
election Luke was on the ground during
the election campaign and he you went up
to I think Debbie Wasserman Schultz and
who was it Charlie Gibbs uh yes Charlie
Gibbs and Obama's uh chief of staff and
and spokesperson and I asked him exactly
why did your Administration personally
call off on the assassination of a 15
year old
signed off on the on the assassination
of a 15 year old American citizen and
the response I got by by Mr Gibbs was he
should have had a better father this
this actually got that's a this was an
American how did I forget that story
yeah that's like in my but that's that's
not just Obama you know of course he was
the president but that's Biden too Biden
was it was very deeply involved in the
in the in the Iraq operation oh he likes
to it's funny how remember uh did bin
Laden's dead Detroit's alive I don't
know you've been to Detroit lately like
he very much liked to marry himself to
all of the wins of the Obama
Administration and I think mainly to
appeal to Black voters
um and not it's not marry himself to any
of the failures of the Obama's
administration of which there are many
thanks for checking out this segment
from the timcast IRL podcast if you want
to watch live you can check out this
channel Monday through Friday at 8 pm
now don't forget to smash that like
button subscribe to this Channel and if
you want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time